so we mentioned exoplanets what about
earth like or i don't know what the
right distinction is if is it habitable
or is it earth-like planets but what are
those different categories and how can
we tell the difference and detect each
right right so we're not at earth-like
planets yet
all the planets we're finding are so
different from
what we have in our solar system they're
just easier planets to find but like
in which way for example there could be
a jupiter-sized planet where an earth
should be
we find planets that are the same size
as earth
but are orbiting way closer to their
star than mercury is to our sun
and they're so close that because close
to a star means they also orbit
faster and some of these hot super
earths we call them
their year their time to go around their
star is less than a day
and they're heated so much by their star
they're heated so much by the star
we think the surface is hot enough to
melt rock so instead of
running out by the bay or the river
you'll have like liquid lava there'll be
liquid lava
lakes on these planets we think and
life can't survive way too hot the
molecules for life would just be
molecules needed for life just wouldn't
wouldn't be able to survive those
temperatures
we have some other planets one of the
most mysterious things out there
factoid if you will is that the most
common type of planet we know about so
far
is a planet that's in between earth and
neptune size
it's two to three times the size of
earth and we have no solar system
counterpart of that planet
that is like going outside to the forest
and finding some kind of
creature or animal that just no one has
ever seen before and then discovering
that is the most common thing out there
and so we're not even sure what they are
we have a lot of thoughts as to the
different types of planet it could be
but people don't really know i mean what
are your thoughts about what it could be
well one thought and this is more when
we want to be rather than might be
is that these so-called mini neptunes we
call them
that they are water worlds that they
could be scaled up versions of jupiter's
icy moons
such that they are planets that are made
of more than half of water
by mass so yeah and what's the
connection between water and life
and the possibility of seeing that from
a gas perspective
okay so all life on earth needs liquid
water
and so there's been this idea in
astronomy or astrobiology for a long
time called follow the water
find water that will give you a chance
of finding life
but we could still zoom out and the kind
of the community
consensus is that we need some kind of
liquid
for life to originate and to survive
because molecules have to react
if you don't have a way that molecules
can interact with each other
you can't really make anything and so
when we think of all the liquids out
there
water is the most abundant liquid in
terms of planetary materials there
really aren't that many liquids
like i mentioned liquid rock way too hot
for life
we have some really cold liquids like
almost gasoline like ethane and methane
lakes that have been found on
one of saturn's moons titan that's so
cold though
and for exoplanets we can't study really
cold planets because they're just simply
too
dark and too cold so we usually so we
usually are just left with
looking for planets with liquid water
and
to your point it's remember as
we talked about how planets are less
than a pixel
in in that way to say so we can't see
oceans on a planet we're not going to
see continents and oceans not yet anyway
but we can see gases in the atmosphere
and if it's a small rocky planet
and this is going into some more detail
it's a small if we see a small rocky
planet with water vapor in the
atmosphere
we're pretty sure that means there has
to be a liquid water reservoir
because it's not intuitive in any way
but water
is broken up by ultraviolet radiation
from the star or from the sun
and on most planets when water is broken
up into h
and o the h the hydrogen will escape to
space
because just like when you think of a
child letting go of a helium-filled
balloon it
floats upwards and hydrogen's a light
gas and will leave from earth
leave from the planet so ultimately if
you have water
unless there's an ocean like a way to
keep replenishing water vapor in the
atmosphere that water vapor should be
destroyed
by ultraviolet radiation got it so
there's a
okay so the there's a need for liquid
i mean i guess what is water well is
water essential is
other liquids i mean the chemistry here
is probably super complicated there's
not it does but you know there's not an
infinite number of liquids
right there's maybe like five liquids
that can exist inside or on the surface
of a planet
and water is the one that exists for the
largest range of temperatures and
pressures
and it's also the easiest type of planet
for us to find and study is one with
water vapor
rather than a cold planet that has
ethane and methane lakes
what's your personal in terms of
solar systems and planets that you're
most hopeful about
in terms of our closest neighbors that
um you kind of have
a sense that there might be uh somebody
living over there or there's bacteria or
somebody that looks like us
i'm hopeful that every star nearby has a
because it almost has to for us to make
progress we have to have that dream
condition
so the dream condition is like life is
just super abundant out there
yeah the dream yes the dream condition
is that life is super abundant and it's
based on
the thought that if there is a planet
with water
and continents that it also has the
ingredients for life and that
the kind of base does the base
the base kernel thought is that
if the ingredients for life is there
life will form that's what we're holding
on
with the relatively high probability yes
that's it
you